[Music]
all right now are across the pond all
over the world segment tonight on this
program we've been telling you since
before the 2020 election way before the
2020 election that Joe Biden is weak
Pharrell a cognitive mess and therefore
unfit for office now the New York Times
recently published a piece declaring
that Biden was pushing the boundaries of
age it's not the first article they've
written on this and that article
prompted our friend across the pond
Piers Morgan to write his own op-ed in
the New York Post and Pierce thinks yep
might be time to invoke the 25th
Amendment remove Joe Biden from office
now Pierce calls Joe Biden a Monumental
liability not just to America but to the
world and a weak leader who won't take
responsibility for any of his policies
or failures and Piers joins us tonight
uh Pierce great to have you back what
you said is true I've been right from
day one and I've been attacked for
speaking the obvious yes but it's now so
bad and the consequence is so severe in
my view
that you're correct but I don't see it
happening in this country and you just
lost Boris Johnson in your country
well it's a very interesting parallel
good evening Festival Sean very
interesting parallelism but Boris
Johnson hey we have a mechanism to get
rid of of prime ministers and we've just
used it where senior members of his own
party effectively launched a coup
against Boris Johnson and drove him out
of office after two and a half years of
his tenure in America obviously it's far
more complicated but I do think in the
case of President Biden right now if
you're a Democrat looking at the poll
that came out alongside this piece of
the New York Times the New York Times
poll was quite extraordinary two-thirds
of Democrats do not want Joe Biden to
run again in 2024 and over 90 percent of
Democrats under 30 feel that way about
him these are his own supporters and
they clearly recognize what the New York
Times identified in this piece what
you've been saying for a long time what
I've been saying as well for a long time
when the New York Times goes to such a
deep dive
as I read it Sean about you when I got
to these lines like his own AIDS every
time he makes a speech watch with kind
of baited breath gasping in suspense
waiting to see if he commits another
Gaff he's the president of the United
States he's the most powerful man in the
world he's the leader of the Free World
but his own needs have to watch him but
you know what the problem is in horror
just in case he makes another mistake
it's it's terrifying you you see the
void though being filled you see new
alliances emerging China Russia Iran
they're they're forming an alliance that
is a clear and present danger to the
entire world of my view so I think
you're right in your understanding that
it's that dangerous and it's that real
uh the problem is I'm looking at the
Democratic party today and then say the
Democratic party of scoop Jackson uh
Zell Miller you know there were more
conservative Democrats back in the day
they don't exist anymore anybody that
were to replace him would still adhere
to what I call this climate alarmist
cult that forces America to look to
countries that hate us the Saudis OPEC
Iran Venezuela Russia for the lifeblood
of our economy now that happened in
Europe but it didn't end too well has it
well it went incredibly badly and in
fact to his credit president Trump kept
sounding the warning about over-reliance
particularly on Russian energy uh you
know some video footage of him
haranguing the German Administration
saying you've got to take this more
seriously and he's been completely
Vindicated Germany has been effectively
held hostage Now by Russia over energy
energy Russia could literally turn them
off if they wanted to and Putin knows
this there's also the rank hypocrisy of
Joe Biden isn't it Sean and this trip to
Saudi in the campaign before he became
president he assured us all that Saudi
should be a pariah that you know that
after the appalling murder of khashoggi
the West Washington Post journalist that
we shouldn't have nothing to do as a
country America with anyone involved in
the Saudi regime and yeah here he is
going cap in hand to Saudi to the very
person who ordered that murder to do a
deal with him over oil because when he
came in into office rather than
encourage Americans and to do their own
oil and gas production he did the
complete opposite and made it more
difficult for them and by doing that he
now has made America dependent on
countries uh like Saudi for the oil at a
time of national and international
energy crisis so there's an hypocrisy
there there is a a weakness in front of
the green agenda which has made him make
policy decisions now coming back to
haunt America you've got inflation
raging to unbelievably high levels and
he's running out of people to blame uh
we appreciate you being with us Piers
Morgan as always thank you don't forget
you can watch Piers his new show
uncensored on foxnation.com hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else